good morning Hank it's Tuesday I really
liked your video on Friday about burnout
and motivation and the various fuels we
use to keep our engines running and it
made me think about how beginning just
after my 24th birthday I spent most of
my nights and weekends working on the
novel that would eventually become
Looking for Alaska I worked all day for
book list and then after work would
usually read the books I'd been assigned
to review for a couple hours and then I
would write until 11:00 or midnight
every night and this was possible
because I was burning in the smithy of
my soul and extremely efficient but
dirty fuel called resentment like
despite the fact that I'd benefited from
all manner of privileges and good
fortunes I somehow managed to imagine
myself as a plucky underdog who'd been
the victim of grave injustice 'as these
injustice is included being dumped by a
girl I loved not being as handsome as I
wished to be and not having had any
breaks in my nascent publishing career
now in actuality I'd had many breaks
like I happen to have an editor at book
lists and Eileen Cooper who mentored me
through the writing process also I had a
job at bookless that paid me albeit
modestly to read books and write about
them but whatever you can have 70
million YouTube subscribers and still
imagine yourself as a plucky underdog
the human capacity for self-pity is
truly endless
and for good reason because no matter
how fortunate we are our condition is
kind of pitiable even the most powerful
humans are fragile and mortal creatures
in a very large universe that is
indifferent to their needs but I digress
right so I was 24 and I was able to work
more or less constantly fueled by this
overarching resentment and here's the
thing it worked like I got a lot done
and some of it was good or at the very
least impressive which is what I really
wanted of course I wanted to impress
people I wanted to show them how clever
I could be about narrative structure
about the distance between the story and
the truth about precipitation metaphors
etc and for me that's the problem with
resentment as fuel it makes your work
entirely about you like the story I was
writing had no guts its griefs grieved
on no universal bones to borrow a
Faulkner phrase the narrator in that
story could look hard at everyone except
for himself and the story felt distant
and cold as if it was being recounted
when it needed to feel like it was being
revealed to steal a line from
Shakespeare resentment is a fire that
burns with more light than heat
I haven't read Looking for Alaska in
almost 15 years and to be honest I don't
remember that much about it but from
what I can gather almost none of what
people liked about that story was in
those drafts that were fueled by the
effective but toxic fire of resentment I
think I needed to write all that stuff
to understand what was wrong with miles
his way of looking at other people and
also what was wrong with my way but to
finish the book miles needed to grow up
and so did I I had to find a fuel that
burned warmer if less bright and that
took years but eventually Looking for
Alaska did become something I worked on
as a gift for other people rather than
as like a document of my attempted
cleverness that said I still find myself
returning to resentment as fuel and
having to learn again and again that
while it can make me productive it
doesn't produce much I'm proud of three
last things first Rosie Anna and I are
hiring someone in Indianapolis to help
us make the things that we make if
you're uncommon ly organized and really
good at calling strangers which is to
say nothing like me then please check
out the link in the doobly-doo to
speaking of things Rosie Anna and I are
making if you're part of the life's
library book club our Q&A with author
Jacqueline Woodson will be January 31st
at noon Eastern Time more info below and
lastly if you were in need of some
excellent Valentine's nerdfighter share
and has you covered you can get these at
dftba.com Hank thanks again for your
video I will see you on Friday